welcome to Destiny's children our weekly
let's play series in which everyone's
favorite fireteam make their way through
the wonderful world of destiny or at
least try to on this week's episode I go
all Legolas on an entire crucible
fireteam where's Gondor in the Westfold
fell the fireteam go to town on a pair
of witches there's a lot of numbers this
is Carol Vorderman stream and we suffer
at the hands of the man with the Golden
Gun
[Music]
the new stuff has been available for
what an hour an hour
all right sick so let's do this a new
stuff I reckon we start got a flash
point out the way get some powerful gear
and then maybe try some cruise books
have you tried you into this yeah yeah I
played a bit it's pop my milestones but
I haven't really been playing it like
intensely under my own volition I played
a bunch of it I can tell mr. 217 so last
week obviously we tried to get the Rat
King if you notice I'm actually using
the right king right now when I tried it
again on the weekend it turns out we
were just going about it that the
completely wrong way instead of speeding
through the way that I managed is to
just clear out areas and then double
back and collect all the Rings where no
enemies with us all right hang about do
the Rings not vanish but no you have to
they what they'll stay there until you
hit the first rings the first ring make
the rest of oh my god we were just bad
I've got a pro tip for people this is
something that I have done in the last
couple weeks so this is a where'd Lucia
stunning is a public event always here
if you're trying to get the mitre mini
tall one of the quests one of the sub
quests is to get a bunch of head shots
with a weapon and the best place to do
it is here like after a while as a
high-level enemy spawns in that corner
even though it's a dead end
there's nothing there he spawns there
and he sends a bunch of those cheap
enemies out so you can basically stand
here and line up headshot their headshot
and you'll get like 50 you need to get
50 kills alone and then you need 25
without reloading so like you stand here
every three kills reload and you'll get
it done in about five or ten minutes I
just noticed they're pretty much all my
weapons are gold even your soul I'm gold
gold hand cannon yeah
got the Drang which is all gold looks
like the man with the golden guns weapon
but me the Golden Gun and then my rocket
launches go I've got weapon cord it does
not compute
I did a great base about this weapon
called critical SAS on twitter.com force
it should be my new pin 3 yeah we just
fell in time we got a minute 45 yeah
wait guys a secret chesty hello I was
here the other day and I was doing the
head legendary Engram oh is it where is
it is it just a just a loot chest over
here you are very trapped whoa the
bubble spawned on us why that's not that
always happens to me hey I was just
saying how I was in this area before
doing the headshot quest and someone
activated the heroic mission and the
tank drop told me I should say by the
way I just remember this that tip I gave
about going into that corner yeah I that
was actually told to me by my younger
brother who if he sees that again I
don't credit him he is going to be like
he's gonna be in the salt mines for the
rest of the day he's gonna eat all your
food you're stealing my strats and just
giving them away free Telamon easy
I've actually cheat code central yeah
I'm just hanging out in the next public
event waiting for it oh there you are
why am i fighting for my life over there
where's Dave oh hello kratos suck ela
face last week after trying to do that
night for strike i left this game not
enthused about it and then i immediately
went homeless like pain obviously yeah
and it's in that week I've come to
really like it again I mean that thing
that's a lot of people have just been
binging destiny since its release which
is fair if that's what you want to do
but for me it's the game that I can it's
it's nicely simplicity I can just pick
up and put down at will all right kill
the witch on the left first
which which which one looks the joke
doesn't work cuz I told you exactly
which one that's not gonna stop me from
trying be it Russell oh yeah we so we
have obviously work what's up dude you
know it's mostly used for coffee orders
what means as well what memes I mean and
basically with the movie it being
released recently it's been a long
wrestling going on in the car I really
liked it like what it this is why I have
the what's I've reviewed I'm gonna see
it pretty well yeah yeah yeah thing is
when I went when I went to see the movie
maker cells when I wrote in the what's
up group that was going on here made
sure to specify yes I like the movie
that has called it featuring the clown
based on the novel by Stephen King
alright I'm gonna sue for this guy as
soon as he comes I'm gonna super him as
well hopefully he'll die real faster
where all the purple is
there's a lot of numbers as a low
numbers if sorry but right now that was
a lot of numbers as well watch it in my
gold rocket launcher oh wait I think
that's the fastest we've done that yeah
polic event look how far we've come
right I'm gonna kill this fish a night
before we go anywhere this is this is
exactly what I'm saying so he appears
and spawn of the thralls
and you just stand right back there aim
down the sides over here and if you hit
the first headshot just keep shooting
and you'll hit every single headshot
after it and then all very quickly a cow
theory of someone has risen we go in the
farm the farm is so another farm sorry
the farm is only filled with people who
are handing in the Sturm quest now like
loads of level 20s will just land in the
farm runs the lady and it was pop-up
saying like found rang and rang and rang
alright what's the next yes power level
271 crucible you can do some crucible
you have an air bubble all we have to do
like 9 of these guys what look who's
here ah 269 Paulo or can I get a nice no
cuz I was just a little talk about
Pennywise he was gonna kill you you'd a
poacher on I'm an adult now he wouldn't
go for me
supremacy let's go see how we fare in
the crucible
I agree come on increase it'll be fair
nice this is basically a Kill Confirmed
efficiency 15 permanence with solar 15 5
with my own okay defeat 15 unipolar
solar final bro I'm dead
oh oh oh my sensitivity is too high yeah
I just pick up their crest so they drop
we should be Gucci get out of hair you
scumbag
pick up his crest mang you can recover
your allies ones as well if you have
wasteful put your back town under
somewhere ah
I'm gained your crest Oh spicy oh my god
yeah auto rifles seem to be the best
option for PvP oh wow why did you just
turn into goofy Oh China that solar
kills by she really just trying it kills
keep forgetting to switch I love whoa
bloody ow um kill one man are you nice
house nice was his name stacks stacks on
stacks on stacks I love his voice they
so wholesome jackass
I hate him for a bit how can you hate
you shouts ah
he's such a hole so hey Guardian is it
chief
oh he's getting out doing well huh
pace yeah how can you hate sharks town
he just talks too much he give any words
of encouragement yeah but I don't need
him behind you they call that melted
hangout use him let's go oh they're all
kindness let's go what don't throw
grenades at me rude honestly
oh come on a little bit Thomas to watch
all this three I'm supposed to reload
with the midday button somehow idea the
guy go yeah Mase I'm with you I'm with
you nice nice nice get that crest girl
[Music]
where they spawn and where they spawn in
there's two crest over there I think the
trader kills okay got roughly Pontius
God dang it
damn moving my hand and accidentally
pressing Emily but oh wow wow I also got
people mean loving those powerful this
is a challenge oh yeah hate a rocket
rocket lunch they're all there
all of this heavy ordnance going on Wow
flat ground so casual Friday here we go
so all back to it all for me see that
Wahlberg Wow oh [ __ ] my god reload you
prick my prick I mean that guy go to try
360 ma6 going a couple gets steep isn't
coming out right I mean any boat shot by
someone else but on his way down I'd
appliquéd him in the face a child you
again that all but a fight ah the whole
jumping at you
Strether jumping as a strategy as a
wallet or worse
ah and like jetpacking behind walls at
the last second listen as a warlock in a
very attacked oh no really can I convert
my shoulder barge into a kill I've got
me bow and arrow I don't actually think
it's the best super for PvP but yeah
we're not trying to very much this is
still in our sights I've got you in my
sights
all right I'm gonna sleep over these
guys Chronicle on I think okay they're
all that got one he's trapped there so
feel free to shoot him yeah yes
Jonah barge in to kill Wow got a couple
shutdowns who's got oats leashing I
don't I don't take it away from me cuz I
got no I didn't take you oh when ready
ten I'll try and keep you alive by just
a scientist when he got me it 20 left so
oh no he's just solid shoot him it's a
real old no golden guns yeah there's my
house now show them the true meaning of
okay okay I'll go to show and then think
oh yeah my super each ah I'm 40 charge
oh that's to them of the regex it's not
over
good old wholesome Jack's chefs Jackson
okay range I got two down
Oh one was an invisible boy all right
well good effort lives
ah just immediately so you put me Oh
still Madrid you it's still murdering
you know if your clinics be there yeah a
little bit
fifteen hundred let's go oh it's I'm
just caught in things by like the
ecology of your names yeah we did this
one less sweet me mmm yeah this man I've
played this with you guys I don't if we
did it
holy crap it just oh it just shoes good
shoes grenaded but wow that's a can see
I'm gonna go for a I got sugar yeah
there's lots of man's here where are you
at man see can go veins free fire
yeah be reloading there's 99 round rub
99 I'm big bullets oh man I just got
here as well get pre fired son these
come on guy come tunnels this is not a
hunter weapon but god damn is it fun
artist you know del without guys running
away from but I was do you focus pow pow
pow pow pow pow pow pow
they call me
Waka Flocka not doing one this one where
the boy go okay who's trying it he's
giving it a big oh okay
brah see it look at these new one just
like you blaze our path for the rest of
us
cheese shacks shacks I love shacks we're
going zoning I'm grabbin bizzle Jax is
weird man it's only casually I'll give
her watch it's not weird he is man he's
too nice he's like heard in a world
that's like you know words only under
threat by aliens it's nice to have a
nice boy everyone used to say about all
the British game show hosts and look
where we are now talking about there's a
guy at a sniper in the brain
oh this two guys are great Davis all we
needs a picture when we go for a our
whole trial B oh I uh there we go avenge
me
Oh didn't fire faster needs to spin up
if you go back and watch this footage
you'll be will be able to everyone be
able to see all my tics mine is bite
your lips yeah I am I feel like sure my
dear yes I also do the ad mouth a gaping
yeah I this I just look really angry
when I'm playing yeah I know it's that
was like the first episode and I just I
just look mad like oh he's got the big
gun as well I'm really not this is a
great not happy to be here I really
can't just focus on my recoil this is
some else it's amazing I'm the really
only time again all these kills this
season time let's go let's go I'm
exhausted
there they breathe and pressing fire I
don't even know why I was doing this
room is some guy in a tunnel si si si si
si si yes oh there's a bunch of em oh
I've got my sleeper will you calm down
please
[Music]
hahaha weapons which Sun Oh comic every
action in this time a game I think I
mean yes bring it out son yes I say that
but I can't high Golden Gun I have my
bow and arrow I got my grounder pounder
I have my emperor palpatine I thought oh
sure but the Rings has chosen different
weapons we're going to be oh yeah I'm
going to be two in that boys eat that
scumbag
taking a there can be you guys get to
see I'll try and defend be from the
apron yeah you better run I mean duck
down underneath it
no way
oh dang
Daniel played myself there's a guy head
called Penn on the school of jomi
great name here you better run away from
my bullets coward
stop exploding me kill me yeah oh what a
QB in there
you've been siphoning babe did you be a
ferment and cycle okay there's three of
them coming from C to B I think let them
come was gone door when the Westfold
fell enemies close
haha he's done it oh he's done it all
them dead
get out of my house B is where I live
keep doing this I keep using my super
when they're like you know already
excited I wasn't good few kills has all
four than that yep
hey so I gotta get me sweet business is
fun let's get more kiss those with my
pistol okay pistols pistol kill thank
you I want the Pistons GG legendary
Engram let's go play that chest armor
looks dope yes better it looks let me
see it's a new character
it's on the character yeah but front
looks alright I like it why is there any
three of us because they couldn't much
make anyone else are we gonna be against
four don't worry it's two three on my
screen that's awesome I three of us Oh
tell my mind shut up okay
you grab that least I'll go help avenge
town okay me I found nice boy Dave I'm
gonna hang around with him now
okay yeah oh wow oh it's three on three
now for some reason I think it's go over
the power armor grenade in the parameter
because I'm a massive jerk a sound you
just said what's our sound yeah so much
so almost stepped in poo something you
listen see so you may just is sound like
a squelch yeah but there's a guy over
there
I'm scared be invisible oh we've got
someone else Oh they've got someone else
I'm scared for you find out coming I
take them like they grow from trees
I drink their milk shake I drink it up
Oh Dave behind grab that how come if I
have a rifle and you have a rifle and my
rifle which is shoots I drink their milk
shake feel bad for that like I was afk
your allies feast and the glory you've
served them
yes shacks checks a shaft thing all
right
that's what off isn't it no you know we
went you a flash go - sure flash I was
going for shaft I died I mean at least I
can't get your crucible your crucible
your crest shop dude no they can oh damn
you've pushed me off so you get what's
in the car oh yeah stop jumping you
coward stop jumping you oh yeah yeah the
sky don't say no this is really itchy
and this is on our gravestones this
guy's just gonna say hey guys me Lucy
James tomorrow saying
they do it justice names name that I
have to jump over a things I stopped the
male brain safe references I couldn't
ask for about you that he's doing us
yeah I mean dr. robotnik's mean bean
machine is it Spike Milligan tombstone
that reads see I told you I was sick but
God to show the by himself off the map
was it no Pro shorter Barger so I'm
gonna go that way yes for that shacks
we're clearly in the lead right now but
you still went and sell offense it's
gotta be somewhat neutral honey no it
doesn't it go shacks he all the
Guardians equally yeah oh the blue on
this which means about clearly are the
good ones
ice cream wet dough goodbye Kristen oh
you senpai 21 Oh
in the arrogance mega weeb Oh speak to
Shaq to collect your reward
I will I love speaking to Shaq see did
that it's a good egg I would why don't
you just shut up to go but I won't touch
that one horn he's got enough anything I
killed me the most pathetic noise no you
sure that wasn't because I just went
I've heard all of your pathetic noises
Lycia voice comes open that's why do I
[ __ ] yeah just run at me so I don't like
my voice
you haven't knows Russell yeah camping
over here kill the Goldman absolutely
see Shaq's
was it wrong
Oh
martyrdom oh there's so many lads boys
are bad boys boys what you gonna do I
would subscribe to your soundcloud
though my hot rap something got a solid
fan let's go let's go run into a wall I
know I punched you first you give me
your thing and leave listen are you
senpai please Korea coming warlock peace
get my face shags
pat my back yeah are you try to use that
old flowing strategy did you strategy
will flow down here you upload to your
float to me that in control Jeremy
yes sir
can't so close you to watch it man I
that will never happen
watch what okay
I came in like a wrecking crew oh I just
need to use power on there now
power on oh I'm oh you made those not
unless I get to it first stop it
you're sliding jump it run stop it one
you shall not escape me come on babe
let's get medieval on someone's ass go
full Legolas
why is this guy died there we go you've
gone this one was in the air yeah
they're the bone arrow isn't great for
PvP Oh kind of a direct hit just doesn't
kill them pick up your locks look people
in place all right guys don't try and
chest I'm fully charged doctor
all right the TFC references either go
back to where you came from
I love the jump in front of your chair
whenever you encounter whenever you get
into a firefight you do this you want to
execute that otherwise is oh yeah you
were making some really weird noises
when you play Marvel vs. Capcom yes sir
by the way yeah what a fan I were like
you know how if you're using that
joystick like it very last for energy
money is devastating ah hello double
kill it's me your boy Satan David
legendary I discuss is your play of the
game
hey let's go I just dock that rocket
Michael Jackson moonwalk immediately
dismantling it goodbye
that's it for this week after a mixed
bag of adventures if there are any
challenges you'd like to see the fire
team take on then please leave your
suggestions in the comment section down
below if you enjoyed make sure you like
the video and remember to subscribe for
more rad destiny 2 content